[Music]
everybody's here
[Music]
all right everybody say hi to the ron's
hello hey patrons
um as you know i took the responsibility
of
picking the topic for this week which i
immediately passed on
to the patrons which i think is a good
idea they came up with a lot of good
ideas
yeah i like the rawls idea i was sad
that one didn't win what was it again
um this is a and j
they want us or yeah this is actually
two people so i can say they
uh got the correct pronouns they wanted
us to debate and compare
your guys's thing which is the rawls
stuff
with uh the dellari stuff the
micropolitics
oh like like delizian and uh dulles and
guitar politics versus rawls politics
yeah so i think libs would be
interesting libs versus non-libs
versus incoherent radicals excuse me
shots fired already um
you guys can become [ __ ] vegetable
all that you want i'll [ __ ] happily
take a set of
principles and rights any day yeah go
live live in the margin
of like nothingness of like a poorik
nothingness if that's even a word yeah
just how about the
margins of philosophy yeah just give
everyone resources and that'll be great
distributive justice there is no race
at least at least we understand what the
hell it means
anyway that would have been fun as you
can see that would be fun yeah one of
the
the second most liked one was uh from
gennadios
who says talk about existentialism
that'd be good i wouldn't that'd be good
we could do
kierkegaard to nature no we should start
with augustine for example we should do
we should do so man i mean come on
uh well of course i'd be included um
the one that won the vote is from matt
h sembiotics dot dot dot
or dairy dot question mark okay
so pretty open-ended very open um oh
this is one of my favorite
patron names apples to apples dust to
dust
oh that's good he or she
wanted us to do beaudry art on the pod
that'd be fun yeah that'd be cool and i
think pre
pre-1981 beaudrier because i always talk
about
post 1980 beaudry art
oh some interesting suggestion
suggestions prophet overlord said
uh marshall mcluhan we haven't even
brought him up i don't think yeah are we
are we in a hot medium right now is this
is podcasting hot or cold it's super hot
it's only auditory plus he is the sage
of toronto
and we are the the new sages of toronto
i remember somebody telling me that uft
ufc
i know he was at u of t but i heard he
had a class at your anyway it doesn't
matter
he might have had a class at new york
but like youtube has like a center
they have like a center named after him
like the marshall mcluhan center for
communication studies or something
yeah and his teacher harold innis also
has a building
down the road on philosopher's walk yeah
and his colleagues college too one of
the colleges of u of t
is uh is named after him too yeah that
would be fun to do him
yeah yeah you talk about how we're all
in this tribal space of simultaneity
nowadays
yo what's that cro i think it's a
cronenberg movie it's
like set in toronto um james woods
video drone and it's very
mcclellan-esque oh yeah literally like
this weird mcluhan figure
has videotapes that he gives the
protagonist they're talking to him
even though he's supposed to be dead
it's pretty [ __ ] up oh and the tv has
sex with them that was pretty amazing
it'd be cool to do the older cronenbergs
yeah up to existence
his newer stuff is a little more
commercial i have to say i'm kind of
upset that like i've never had a tv that
actually like reached out to try to like
fellate me
i mean i would probably buy that just
for the one time experience but we
haven't gotten there yet
we should not see the question what is
canadian philosophy one day
yeah the toronto school we like to
represent
because some of so many of our exports
are
awful awful humans lauren southern
george jp stephanie
i'm doing my best to not bring him up
every single day but
he's back though he's back in the mix
he's back in health he's ready for
more punches from the bottom of the
podcast barrel
god he's so emotional too like it's it's
interesting to watch like i watched his
recent video and he's just
like that's not a bad thing or anything
right like i'm obviously being emotional
is fine it's just i find it like a
striking
feature of his personality that that
like everything hits him so hard and
deep you can tell like you know
yeah when he's talking about something
he'll choke up it's like but then his
image is like being this
solid guy with his shoulders back and a
clean dick and a
tiger because he sees that it's because
he feels the profundity and the
and the terribleness of the uh the the
dread of human existence so deep in his
soul that it can't help but overwhelm
him
he's a he's a hard man with a mushy
center
all right since we're already bringing
him up i was not going to do this but i
will ask
because he has a lot to say about
derrida having very evidently never read
anywhere
and the collapse of western civilization
and all that stuff
so i was going to start with this anyway
but now we can connect it to
um his takes and maybe people around him
if you guys watch more awful youtube
than i do you know i do
what do you people what do you hear
about when people are referencing
derrida
in passing including the terms
deconstruction and post-modernism
oh sorry go ahead victor well i was just
gonna say i mean the typical like
caricature right comes from i guess like
the analytic
school right as just being incoherent
makes no sense like those are the
typical critiques like
it's all like flourish and no content
right it's like uh
language uh playing with language for
fun without like actually saying
anything i don't know that's like the
typical
and certain responses searle threw a
chair at darida
okay i kept searching it for that and i
couldn't i couldn't find it but
well maybe it's part of academic lawyers
i always picture deleuze sitting in the
room and then he would say that this is
the moment where a dairy dow was
becoming chair
so you end up with cherry duh also
dario's hot
hey yeah he's a he's a he's got the
smoldering look he's always like he's
always got his
face slightly down slightly turned but
with that sort of
smoldering eyes and the shock of silver
hair
he's striking he's a striking chap isn't
he from
he's isn't he jewish from like uh
algeria
yeah he's french algerian he's always
been kind of but not your orders right
yeah he's jewish yeah he's got he's
interesting
if you're born in algeria did you get
french
citizenship automatically yeah you know
anything about actually considered it
part of the french homeland for a little
while which is one of the reasons they
fought so hard to keep it
in the empire even though you know a lot
of algerians that
by the 1950s were like get the [ __ ] out
bye great film on that
the battle for algiers french film
yeah derry does the guy who's associated
probably most strongly
with the idea that there is no objective
truth
no reality that everything is kind of in
flux
and also the progenitor of
critical theory i guess he's just
smashed in with there which terry does
does talk about critique all the time
but
i wouldn't even call him a postmodernist
yeah yeah i mean he's a
post-structuralist that would be the
proper
word for it like post-modernism came
around
like a little bit later with with
leotard
taking the term out of architecture and
applying it in a more general sense to
like modern culture
yeah and i guess is associated with like
being skeptical of truth but
but like i mean by the time he came
around to talk about it that was a
pretty old idea right like i mean
with nietzsche and other people yeah he
brings up nietzsche and heidegger and
freud
quite a bit i think some of the stuff i
was going over anti-foundationalism
you might say i'd say that's one of the
more the one of the objections that you
see for more sophisticated
analytical critics or i should say like
equally dismissive but not knowing
analytical critics right uh martha knows
bomb wrong essay on derrida
uh whether an essay on daredevil where
she was talking just sternly about
french philosophy
as she more or less said that she felt
that everything that
darren had said had been said uh more
readily more profoundly uh and
more clearly uh prior to daredevil's
writings by wickenstein
right so our basic point is you know why
bother reading daredevil when you can
just go read the philosophical
investigations
and they'll get a lot more out of it uh
and it'll also be
considerably easier than going through
uh grammatology that's an interesting
claim
yeah i mean like that's really not a
true claim but it's
interesting yeah i mean if you if you
want to claim that like the cash outs
are the same
with what they're saying you can but you
can't claim that their like trajectory
in their background is the same like
it's very different in that sense
derrida assumes a whole different sort
of
background of knowledge he's one of
those guys he's really hard to read
because you got to know
a lot about philosophy and metaphysics
and history
he's a lot like heidegger in that sense
you have to have a pretty strong grasp
already
of the tradition and then you've got to
get into that tradition
and sort of critique it from within
using its own terms
so people just dismiss him from the
outside without knowing anything about
what he's talking about
i mean that's your prerogative i guess
but don't pretend that you're
giving a fair assessment i also think
that like um
if you look at like the cash out of
wickensinian analysis uh while it is
highly skeptical in some senses
his own interpretation of his work is
considerably more conservative not
politically
but in terms of its radicalness for um
the way it is that language operates
because he more or less says that
once you've completed a philosophical
analysis you realize frankly that
there's really no point to this because
everyday language
operates just fine without the need for
these kinds of reflective activities
and so philosophers could really only
just leave things as they were
in the famous expression right and that
they only seem weird because
and they only seem weird because you ask
weird questions
like that's what like an analysis of
language vic institution analysis will
show is that like
when you start asking like what is truth
or like what is
meaning that like because that's taking
it out of the ordinary use of the word
that like it becomes weird when actually
in your everyday life it's not weird at
all because it plays a pragmatic
form of life purpose and this uh
this critique that you offered matt that
that
this is or that what what's her name
martha responds it's not a critique
nosebomb's point is essentially that
in her mind at least everything daredev
said had been said earlier and better
and clearer by
ludwig wickenstein right the main thing
that
the main contention i have with that
point is that
wittgenstein does not include historical
analysis
of language and how language comes to
mean he more talks about the everyday
whereas darida is very concerned with
you know the history of philosophy and
discourse theory yeah no i would agree
with that but i mean this guy
goes to my point about how wickenstein
has a bit more of a conservative
approach to language right because
to his mind the kind of settled
practices of ordinary language
what he calls language games in certain
contexts function perfectly fine without
philosophical reflection
uh and so you're kind of cured of this
need to do a theory
and you enter back into everyday life
from a more reflective standpoint
but without feeling compelled to
interrogate the world
and the way a philosopher traditionally
would and i'm sure that eric will point
this out also i don't think that that's
sarah at this point at all right because
one of the things that he showcases and
i think this is what he draws from
heidegger is that
if you look at the history of
philosophical thought and the impact
that it's had
on particularly western or occidental
conceptions of moralist everything
there's this immense deconstructive task
we have ahead of ourselves
to try to show how it is that certain
kinds of presence have been privileged
over others and so the job of the
philosopher is much more radical
than this kind of coming to grips with
everyday life that you see in
wickenstein's analysis
kind of in a kind of an aside but i i
had an analytic
philosophy professor when i was doing my
master's in philosophy and
he like showed me this book that looked
really interesting and i always wanted
to like go and read it and it was
it was basically arguing that do you
guys know what donald davidson is he's
like a super analytic philosopher
yeah like donald davidson and darida are
like come to the exact same conclusions
basically
they do about metaphors yeah
and like other things not the exact same
conclusion but they're they're
definitely in the same ballpark
well this is one of the reasons why i
always got angry that analytical
philosophers criticized him so much
because i was like
if you look at the consequences of the
linguistic turn uh in people like
wickenstein or for that matter in people
like wine or for that orange people like
rorty
a lot of name dropping happening here
bro yeah a lot of name droppings oh
sorry
these ones in some these were all
analytical philosophers of language and
logic who more or less came to the
conclusion
that we can't we have to drop this idea
that language
paints a picture if you want of how the
world operates uh it's a lot more
complicated than that
and since we can't say that language
creates a picture of how the world
operates or for that matter how the mind
operates
we have to drop the idea that our
knowledge can ever have the kind of
certainty
uh that a lot of the philosophers have
wanted it to have right and that's a
very dare idean idea i mean jared would
cash this out very differently
the interesting thing about davidson
though is i know we're name-dropping a
lot but like i the thing that's
interesting about about that is that
like
he never read any like continental
philosophy really like he wasn't he just
like kind of independently arrived at
some of those
uh compatible conclusions even though
whereas like rorty right was somebody
who did end up reading a lot of
continental philosophy and that was what
partly changed his mind
yeah i remember actually we already had
a very famous uh
query i think it was in the early 1980s
when somebody came up to them
i was a continental philosopher and said
you know i'm really surprised that an
analytical philosopher like you would
have this weird history of how
philosophy operates because
it sounds a lot like martin heidegger's
uh and rory said well that's where i got
it from
and this guy was shocked just blown away
because he was like you read martin
heidegger and rory was like oh yeah all
the time
and this is right before i became a lot
more overt about this in the 1980s
writing about how i've learned daredevil
for cohen
all them anyway maybe you guys should or
maybe um we should talk more about
darada even though i don't know yeah
maybe at all
it would be good yeah i yeah i wrote a
paragraph actually
and i'm just gonna diatribe it but it's
okay intended to get anyone who's not up
to speed
um don't worry about all these names
we're it's an analytic versus
continental thing
i'm rambling but i wrote a i wrote a
paragraph on what deconstruction is
because that's the term most associated
and
feared when it comes to derrida
so think of it this way we're used to
thinking of things
as self-identical that means obviously
that a
equals a the ball is a ball and fine
those things are okay um what
deconstruction
gets or what darada notices and gets
worried about is when we think of
self-identical terms in the sense of
giant concepts historical western
philosophy grounding concepts like truth
knowledge or nature and this is your
culture
this is where dereda's problem comes in
and why he
reads things deconstructively
because these terms are historically
situated
and then today uh in in state philosophy
or what
de lis would call state philosophy it's
used to justify
all manner of hierarchies of knowledge
archaeologies of knowledge we might say
and status quo so what he's doing when
the the projects of the 60s and 70s for
derrida are almost
the same for every book and he just
takes a different thinker
um hegel is the gloss book
um rousseau in gramatology and he reads
them
and he finds these these pivot points
you could call them like the pillars
of their systems and says like this
pillar
is grounding the entire structure
of this giant philosophical system
but this pillar isn't exactly what it
looks like
there's actually something else holding
this pillar up that's outside the system
that they're forgetting so they're
assuming a presence that isn't there
sorry i'm almost done um and then we get
to the concept of ghosts
and spectras and suplemo
and traces so when we have traces and
ghosts what are these things they're not
full things but they're an indication
that something's missing
from the system they're a half thing
like a ghost is a half
person or not a real person same with a
trace it
reveals that there was something here
that is no longer
here um this is where he gets into the
concept of metaphoricity
that our concepts like knowledge truth
nature
are actually based on metaphors that we
have forgotten
our metaphors so
these are absences they're indications
of absences so for daradat to get over
hegel and that's kind of the project
same as de lis but he does it in a
different way get over hegel
more or less we have to find the ghosts
we have to find what has been repressed
and we have to find those things that
have been banished from official
philosophy or official western knowledge
and science
and then bring those things back so
thank you guys for permitting me to
diatribe i think
if you want to point to any of those
things and say that i'm incorrect
or give examples uh that would be a good
way to start i think
yeah yeah i think another another good
way to just
begin what talking about what dairy does
up to
is to say he's he's he's almost taking
over also this project that
that heidegger put in motion this
critique of western
metaphysics going all the way back to
plato
and even further to the sophists and the
pre-socratics before him
so derrida takes over this sort of
critique
and when you're talking about him
finding those those lacks those
exclusions
those things that ground knowledge he's
he's also thinking about the way that
western metaphysics
is predicated predicates knowledge on
certain things
like the idea of a center
organizing the whole entire structure of
knowledge or the idea
of speech being more important than
writing
and writing just being a derivative form
of speech
and also being constitutive of science
so he's taking on over this critique of
like two thousand years
of western metaphysics uh and that's
where his historical understanding so
when he's talking about history
it's usually a history of western
metaphysics
philosophy and science and
he is trying to get into that tradition
and sort of
use it on its own terms to critique it
and he does this for instance if you
read structure sign and play that's like
his first
sort of major essay or well it's a talk
he gives at john hopkins
in 1967 i believe
so the whole story is kind of funny
because structuralism
has come into france in a big way in the
60s
and it's almost like this conference was
where
the french structuralist claude levy
strauss was going to be
kind of i guess you could say crowned
king of structuralism
and and then darida and like so
structuralism's barely been around for
very long it kind of took this weird
route
from ferdinand to sir through all these
linguistic circles to france
and then structuralism became big and
then almost immediately derrida shows up
on the scene
and kind of just throws a wrench with
this with this essay really
into the whole thing and the essay gets
right
into it to say that the concept of
structure something has happened
let's call it an event and no one knows
by the way that's a great intro if you
don't know darada never read him um
structure shine and play is great
but nobody knows who this guy is so
levi strauss is being celebrated um this
is 1966
and darada nobody knows who he is yet in
1967
he publishes three massive books so
gramatology
writing indifference and i can't
remember the third one
was it the husserl book on um uh voice
and phone oh yeah
yeah you're right speech and phenomena
so he drops
three books after showing up unknown and
like basically dissing
dissing structuralism yeah and the three
big books would probably you could say
the
like focus on rousseau one of them
focuses
on husserl and one of them maybe focuses
on
i don't know plato and sosur and a
couple other people as well
well i wanted to cash this out actually
in two different ways
to kind of bring to light the political
implications of this
and one of them is how feminists have
interpreted dairy death feminist
erudians i should say
and the other is how postcolonial theory
uh has interpreted there
since he's had a big influence on both
for better or worse uh depending on who
you ask right
but one of the things that as eric
pointed out i think was innovative about
darada's
analysis is how he talks about how what
is repressed
uh or what is marginalized nonetheless
always still exists
in a certain relation to what's put
forward right and in fact what's put
forward as being
better or more real uh or morally
superior
is in many senses dependent uh upon
what's being repressed uh and one
example postcolonial theorists give
i brought up saeed a little while ago is
the dependent of this notion
this notion of western civilization uh
on its other
uh in this case usually the east right
uh and people like gayatri spivak who
wrote the introduction to algorithology
for
english audiences made this point
expressly right and translated the whole
thing
yeah exactly um just we have this notion
of the so-called western world
right uh but if you actually ask people
what it means to be western it's really
difficult to pin that down
right does it mean that you know you're
a christian nation while there are
christian nations in africa latin
america
we don't consider them part of the west
right does it mean you're beholden to
enlightenment values while japan is
beholden to enlightenment values you can
make the argument that
china is beholden in many ways to
enlightenment values we don't consider
them part of the west right
uh does it mean that you're committed to
greco-roman civilization well you know
record roman civilization had a
tremendous impact in
egypt the hellenistic world all the way
to india right
and so the idea that gives up is what is
meant by the west is usually just
defined by its opposite and typically
this conception of the east as being
more barbaric more effeminate
uh more dedicated to unreason and so on
and it's always through this process of
juxtaposition
that the so-called western world has
been able to define itself and unless it
had this available
it wouldn't have been able to do this
for a very long period of time
right uh and we continue to do this to
this day uh as spevak would say
right uh the other point that i wanted
can we reflect on that for a second
well i just want to bring up the one
other example because it's a really
similar one and it's something that i've
been thinking about more recently
yeah well you can bring it up in a
second but yeah like
jordan peterson in his defense of
western civilization
is very correct to identify derrada as
an enemy
i think we should all right very da
excuse me i don't think he is an enemy
of western civilization per se i think
he would say that
actually the whole point that he's
trying to make is that we shouldn't
necessarily even think about things in
terms of western civilization and if we
do we have to recognize
precisely this is how this exclusionary
method
is constitutive uh
of our entire conception of ourselves as
westerners right yeah
and i'm not sure i'm not sure i'm okay
with the implication that he had
some kind of malicious intent towards
the west though it's almost like as if
he's trying to show us a better way of
doing things isn't that why any
philosopher does what they do is because
they're
showing us something that we can i meant
i meant the point is
the west western civilization doesn't
exist
for for the reasons that matt just said
yeah it's a it's a complete fabrication
yeah so so ethno ethnography doesn't
exist
because anthropologists just go out into
the field and that's also
the west they go to they go to mc africa
and make indonesia and they're already
places
part of the west because the west does
well this is i mean i'm just joking but
there's
there is it's not a coincidence that
he's going after an anthropologist
in this first 1967 essay and he talks
about ethnography
and what is the condition behind
ethnography
well just in a very loose way it's it's
the west starting to introspect
and starting to say okay well what's not
western okay let's send our
anthropologists out into the field
to figure out what's not western so we
can then get a better
idea of ourselves so it's like a project
that comes
along with self-knowledge well yeah i'm
curious
like so how would you would you make a
distinction between like the west
and enlightenment values like i think
there is a difference but like i know
obviously jordan peterson's talking
about what the west but then there's
also this idea of like enlightenment
rationalism or
enlightenment philosophy which is often
associated with western philosophy as
opposed to like eastern or other
philosophy and like i guess my like
brief take it's like
something that actually came up when i
was taking a nietzsche seminar like we
were
we were asking whether like nietzsche is
in what is he a break with like
enlightenment uh like like rationality
and like to
like the the consensus at least in that
seminar was like not really like in some
ways like like nietzsche is a
radicalization
of of enlightenment rationalism it's
like pushing rationalism to its like
furthest limits and there's like so i
don't know i wonder if
uh you guys think like like how if that
changes the question or changes the
answer at all to ask it from the
perspective
i think it's important to note that this
doesn't necessarily have to be
as eric would put it a hostile um
way of analyzing things right i mean in
the household book he makes that clear
also right
when it comes to you determining your
own subjectivity uh he's pushes against
health central's idea that you can have
immediate access to some kind of ego
conception and the reason is that
in many ways we conceive of ourselves by
in relation to others who were not
right like i sit there and i think to
myself like well who is matt's
right well matt is unlike victor because
matt is doesn't have family from chile
matt you know doesn't have
dark hair matt you know isn't interested
in the same things and so through this
process of
distinguishing myself from you that i
can sometimes better understand myself
and there's nothing wrong with that
right you know this is something that we
all do and it's necessary
to develop a conception of the self but
we can't
pull ourselves into a conception of
ourself purely subjectively it's always
in relation to some kind of other
right and i think you'd say the same
thing is true about civilizations or
nations or religious groups or whatever
right
sometimes this can be problematic if
it's politically misused or used to
justify various forms of marginalization
right but it doesn't have to be yeah
like western western metaphysics is the
bigger historical frame here so the
enlightenment is
part of that history and the romantics
after that
we're working with the concepts handed
down to them
so you're always working in this
tradition you're either working for it
or working against it but you can't
escape it there's no
sort of cavalier way to just step
outside of it and say ah
i'm free of all of this stuff now or i'm
i'm not doing philosophy anymore because
normally when you just try to do that in
some cavalier kind of dismissive way you
just end up stepping
fully into metaphysics and then you're
not examining
any of your preconceptions you're just
you're just doing
bad philosophy is what he says that's
usually just what happens you just do
bad philosophy what we got to do is get
into the tradition
we got to read the tradition critically
and we got to see
when you guys are talking about like the
centers and the groundings i also like
to talk about the constitutive
exclusions so what needs to be swept
aside
in order to establish the tradition what
goes to the peripheries and the margins
what gets excluded from the center
and that's what that's that's the basic
thing so you're always
the enlightenment is part of the
tradition of western metaphysics
as is the romantic reaction as is
nietzsche freud and heidegger who are
also working in that tradition with
concepts they inherit from the system
isn't it also daredevil
in some ways or not yeah yeah he
outright says yeah he's not working he's
working in the same
tradition as well and he's he just he
sees
in people like heidegger and nietzsche
and freud
a more sustained critique of the ideas
of western metaphysics obviously he
thinks they didn't even take it far
enough but he sees in them the most
sustained critiques of things like
say what are the conditions of objective
truth or
transcendental philosophy and all these
other
all these other concepts is a big list
of them that he has that
that western metaphysics gets along with
so concepts like
substance existence essence presence
subjectivity alathia which is truth
transcendentalism consciousness
conscience in the moral sense
god and man so for instance in the
middle ages right the
transcendental signifier what we'd call
that sort of
organizing center of all knowledge at
that point was god
and then when we get into the
enlightenment tradition god is removed
and what's put in his place human reason
so
reason becomes the sort of center
organizing
that phase of western metaphysics if you
want to call it that
and then after that the argument goes
one of the biggest critiques i've heard
of derrida
is all derrida does is he takes man and
reason out of the picture
and just sort of puts language in the
center which in a way he does but he
does it in a very sort of critical and
self-conscious way that allows us to
sort of
see this history of western metaphysics
that he's talking about
and ways in which we can get at the sort
of
presumptions the truths the the
i don't know what you call them the uh
the the uncritical concepts that they
use
the concepts are not self-critical yeah
and
the kind of ironic thing and i'll just
bring it back to the point you made
about peterson's interpretation and
others like him
when it comes to daredevil because a lot
of uh i figured that a lot of
right-wingers happen to like
heidegger right i think actually had a
much more damning account of the history
of western metaphysics in some of his
periods than daredevil does for all the
reasons eric was talking about right
i mean if you read some of the uh
heidegger stuff in the 1930s
even upwards to the 1940s there's the
sense that the end of western
metaphysics has been
a nihilistic technocratic uh
increasingly
deracinated world and that's why we need
to end philosophy
sometimes very stressed about that and
start trying to move towards what he
calls thinking uh you know it's kind of
original act of thinking again
and i don't think daredevil says
anything like that uh he sometimes says
that
all i'm trying to do is allow us and he
uses the term i think
uh quite literally at least as literally
as dara ever does
you know i'm trying to let you play with
the history that you have available to
you
not by saying that you should reject it
but by loosening it up and as
i said showing you the different
elements and the different weird sides
uh to the history of western metaphysics
that people have marginalized
and this doesn't mean that i'm saying we
can't we'll have to do without a center
or that we've entered in some kind of
apocalyptic time
it just means that we should look at
this as a set of tools
to use in interesting and creative ways
rather than as a set of firm concepts
that must be applied to the world in
this way in order to give us an accurate
picture of it
uh regardless of the discipline you
happen to be in
yeah so you can probably summarize a lot
of
what darry does looking at like two of
the
biggest concepts maybe that he's working
with are the idea
of origins and the idea of universality
making universal claims so you can think
if you're looking at a work that is
either obsessed with origins
or universality you're probably dealing
with some kind of
uncritical western metaphysician who
isn't examining these concepts and
that's exactly what he wants to do in
structure
sign and play because structures have
origins
he talks about for instance the origin
of language
and things have claims to universality
right so when we talk about nature we're
talking about universal
and spontaneous as opposed to culture
which is particular and differs from
structure to structure every culture has
its own structure so there's difference
between them
so he's he's trying to get underneath
these concepts of origin and
universality
and particular and general and
just that for lack i guess you say
deconstruct them look at what are their
what are the main binaries going on here
like male female
nature culture universal particular
all of these sorts of binaries that we
just sort of take for granted that
structure
different areas of knowledge speech and
speech and writing
yeah yeah speech and writing speech and
text yeah all these things he's trying
to get underneath them by saying that
they are
part of this western metaphysical
tradition but he's not trying to get
underneath them he's trying to
show that the well i guess
we're we're using metaphors right like
under cro under closer scrutiny right
yeah under closer scrutiny they do not
hold up to
analysis in a certain in a very specific
sense they the you see that the two
terms
of the binary are actually dependent
on one another and that's a sign that
there's something going on there
that needs to be made explicit
i wanted to ask what we think here about
one of the
most quoted and most uh derided
comments that dereda has made i believe
it's from gramatology
there is nothing outside the text and
this is usually taken
as an indication of derida's
nihilism um and it isn't and i'll throw
it to you
after but yeah we're talking about when
when eric is saying
universality plus this obsession with
origin
what's really being emphasized and
what's emphasized
throughout western philosophy plato
and his idos or aristotle and his uzia
and we can take it all the way to
heidegger's being is they're obsessed
with what's the
presence what's the opaqueness that you
can
basically believe in and trust
to uh give you an accurate presentation
of the world
and then saying there's nothing outside
the text is saying that we can't get to
those things because there's nothing out
there
so would you take this as a
evidence of his nihilism and why not
i don't think so i i would say the the
the passage is already
translated problematically like there is
no outs
cinepa doll's text
text yeah there is no outside text
uh it's it's hyphenated outside text
if you want to translate it a little
more uh
like faithfully uh but like there
there is nothing outside of the text
implies that there's a text
and there's an outside of that text and
there he does saying that there's
nothing outside of the text well no
that's part of the mistranslation
reading
he's saying there is no outside text
there is no
point you can get to outside of the
structure of the text that you're
reading
that the truth will just reveal itself
from that position so
an outside text would be something
like god again to bring it up again god
is outside of the text
in in the bad reading so god is
this is where the scientists want to get
to to with their uh sort of pure
objective perspective
they get outside of the text and they
look into the text
and they can just sort of determine all
of the
truths about the text by just what is
the text why don't we
why don't we establish that yeah so yeah
is it how is this flick kind of this is
a
similar point to like the idea of there
being no archimedean point
of reference yeah yeah that's another
way to put it
yeah the archimedean lever or point yeah
yeah the way i've interpreted it uh and
this might be a little bit
whole to behold into rorty's
interpretation of daredevil with the
reference to the archimedean point that
they teachers made there
uh i should say first off that i think
that some of the materialist criticisms
of darida actually hold here because i
do think that there's a residual
linguistic idealism that you can find in
darada much like you can see it kind of
residual idealism
and heidegger's work uh so i agree with
jesus critique of daredevil in that
respect
along with like fred jameson's and
others right but i do think that this
point has been misunderstood in exactly
the way that eric talked about right
which is essentially that
there's nothing outside of language or
there's nothing outside of the words
that we used and that's pretty
nonsensical
the way that i understand this is just
that there's no pre-interpretive
standpoint
uh you can take when it comes to the
world that's
foundational and that kind of determines
everything else right
things are interpretive the whole way
down right uh and so
when we think about knowledge it's
better to look at it uh in terms of
almost not quite a circle but
free-flowing kinds of interpretation
right rather than this kind of way of
looking at the world
is built upon this kind of way and this
kind of way and then we get to the rock
bottom
uh and that's where we stop when we say
we've reached at least as close to
absolute certainty as we're ever going
to get
right i think this is the idea of play
that he brings up here also
right uh that rather than looking for a
foundation
uh and saying that everything is kind of
hierarchically built on that we just say
uh where there's free flows of
interpretation and there's different
ways of looking at things
uh and it doesn't mean that there's
not better ways of looking at things or
worse always of looking at things
uh but there's no foundationless way uh
of looking at things that determines
everything else
yeah there's no there's only text
outside of text
maybe it's like the positive way to put
it like if you like just as a really
practical example like you read a poem
and you want the meaning of the poem now
so you have various strategies you can
employ and if you believe that there's
an
outside of the text then you might
believe something that well i can get to
the meaning of this poem by appealing to
the author's intention
because the author is outside of the
text so his intention must be the thing
that points to the meaning of the text
or you go into the author's life you do
the biographical
reading so you say okay so he was uh
abused as a child
so this is what this means at this part
of the poem and then he grew up and like
his wife got sick and died so this is
what this means at this point of the
poem
his point is no you what you're doing is
you're just translating one text
using another text you're not getting
outside the text and getting to the
fundamental meaning of it you're just
using one text to translate another text
so it's fine to go and use the author's
intention
as something that guides your
interpretation of the text
but don't pretend you're getting outside
of the text to some kind of
transcendental truth using that method
that's probably a really practical way
of expressing what it means or like you
know what's the meaning of life okay
let's go read the bible because that's
got the meaning of life in it because
god wrote that text and god is outside
the system
so we just need to look at what god
meant to say or
yeah so those are the sorts of like when
you interpret you're always bringing one
text
to another text there's no getting
outside of the text
in like text is sort of in this sense
he's he's very critical but it's a
totalizing kind of thing like everything
is text cause i ask the question what
does that mean if we can go
uh sorry what was your question victor
is it related to that
it is related to that and like it's it's
it's just kind of like i don't know
daredevil well but i was just curious
like how
like this sounds like is this this
different point than kind of like the
phenomenological point
like or which maybe is like kind of like
an idealist point i guess in some ways
but it's a bit different like
that like from a from a phenomenological
perspective at least like you can't ever
like get outside of
like yourself like your like your
perception of the world is always
contaminated by you being an embodied
being
in a specific circumstance so there's no
point at which outside of that that you
could look at yourself
looking at the world and then give like
an objective i don't know
is that related different how is that
different well this is actually what i
wanted to bring up with the critique of
first row that he makes right because
one of the points that he makes and i
actually think wickenstein makes this
point as well right is that
uh the transcendental tradition had this
idea that what's foundational
uh to all of our understanding is the
suggestive like the subjective self
and its cognition right and so if you
ask yourself like well who am i
putting it really basically you'd say
well i am my thoughts
you know my stream of consciousness if
you wanted to use the nautilus
terminology right and so all i need to
do is
listen to what it is that i'm saying and
that voice in math said
is who matt is foundationally right and
daredevil would say
it's absolutely fine to think of
yourself as a stream of consciousness in
some specs but
think about you know where you inherited
this language from right you didn't
invent it yourself
you got it from interacting with other
people around you you got it from
reading books
you got it from hosting podcasts talking
about dereda so when your stream of
consciousness is saying things like
daredevil said this and that
it's because you were interacting with
other kinds of texts right
i want to be clear here though darida
does not talk in phenomenological
terms he's not saying here's you and
here's
like here's your sense of self this is
what i'm chris this is like
how he would critique phenomenal yeah
this is what he's criticizing right and
what consent does the same point where
he says there's no such thing as a
private language or
with a matter of private self right
because we need to inherit our ways of
thinking about
ourselves from the world outside of us
and its languages
and its texts and its cultures right and
so
it's perfectly fine in some some context
to say
who i am is my stream of consciousness
the kind of line of thought that's
running through me
but that's not where interpretation ends
because then of course you could say
well what language have you inherited
what's its culture what's its gestation
what books have you region where does
your education come from so you think
about the world in these kinds of terms
and so we move on to interpreting things
that way right
uh there's no foundational point where i
say who i am is
my subjective stream of consciousness uh
and the word yeah that's
that's subject yeah yeah so
phenomenology
puts subject as the center right okay or
if you're doing if you're
if you're heidegger you're you're doing
existential phenomenology
so what heidegger says is is like if you
if you start reading through heidegger
and you want to get to the important
ideas one of them is like
design is that which takes a stand on
its own being
so existence becomes the center of that
sort of philo phenomenal existence right
i see what you're saying and like
phenomenology did try to like escape the
language of subjectivity
right like mariloponte would have never
said subject he would have said like
phenomenal field or like
embodied mint or something like that but
yeah you're right like basically it's
doing the same work that makes sense
yeah yeah like but the yeah the point is
like with heidegger and
yeah with people who take up the
heideggerian critique is that
you know they they expose the sorts of
metaphysics or in heidegger's language
onto theological assumptions
of of western thought right
but yeah they all they they're
substituting one center for another
they're sent they're they're they take a
structure
and they give it a new center and this
is why
right at the opening daridai uses this
term redoubling
because he's like okay so instead of
just giving you a new structure
i'm gonna think about structure itself
the structurality of structure
what does it mean for there to be a
structure
it means that the free play of language
has to be contained
and what does that containing the center
does that containing
and at this point it's really funny with
the
matt's post-modern conservatism one of
the one of the quotes he puts in there
is rudy giuliani saying the truth is not
the truth and if you read through
structure sign and play
the here's my quote the center is not
the center
there he does says this the center is
not the center
because because but for derrida
the center is at the same time outside
of the structure governing it from the
outside this is the outside text
assumption again
so for classical thought about
structures you have to have this center
this origin or this point of
presence right like presence comes from
the christian tradition right
the the second coming is the the
presence of god will eventually arrive
or with hegel right the presence of what
the phenomenology of spirits or the
presence of spirit
we're eventually going to get to this
point of presence so the
the center is at once the origin the
point outside that gives the structure
its meaning
and it's the eschatology the end point
what's going to come at the end
and he's critiquing all of these notions
like in the same
fell swoop of saying okay but let's
think about structurality itself
and the idea of centers
is he is he assuming though like that he
that he's positing some kind of center
like
like how is he he's wait i can answer
this question okay cause i don't know
daredevil i really don't think he is
because this is one of the critiques of
darada same as so
heidegger critiques nietzsche says no
you're actually still being a platonist
darida then says to heidegger no
actually you're still being a platonist
and now people say oh no darren you're
actually still being a platonist
um for a lot of reasons we don't have to
get into it but everyone's like trying
to kick the can further down the road
and by playing this do you mean that
there's like a hidden there's like a
hidden point of reference yeah there's a
hidden
that the center's being like moved and
then covered
as it always is but darada does this a
little bit different from heidegger in
the sense that he
or his later books after the 60s the 70s
books
are performative which means the form
matches the content
in that he doesn't allow his own books
to have centers so he does
things like having a book and then half
of the book is written in a footnote
and then half of the book is written
like in a in a margin in the literal
margin and each of the texts is saying
different things
and it's kind of like hacky it's a
little bit gimmicky and he only did it
once he didn't
try to like stick to a new writing style
but that's one form of
of doing it then he changes his
vocabulary
in every book he uses different terms
you can use the rk
then he uses presents then he uses
suplemon
then he uses every one of these terms to
basically describe the same
movement but he's picking from all over
philosophy
to assemble this deviant
text as a whole so he keeps he
he doesn't let himself become
a systematic thinker in any part and
then later in this career
then he's writing about forgiveness and
hospitality and
the ghosts of marx and all this stuff so
i
think that you cannot take dereda in the
same way you can take heidegger as
having
a project and by that by virtue of that
he avoids the oh darred is just making
everything language because that's not
true
i don't know i mean i don't know this
doesn't sound like that convincing to me
like
that just sounds stylistic when like but
you you you even just said
he uses different terms to describe the
same movement so there's a movement that
he's working with there's something that
he's doing
like uh yeah but he was saying that it's
the same
i mean i said it's the same i did but
he's doing this by reading text he's not
he's not he's doing it performatively on
each text so first it's through so then
it's hegel then it's i mean
first it's who cyril okay what you're
saying
speaking from a place of zero authority
as someone who's like maybe read like
half of one of jared's books like once
so yeah sorry phil's made an interesting
point which is something really um
intriguing about the way uh he goes
about
uh engaging in philosophical reflection
right which is that
unlike even heidegger who at least in
being in time more or less structured
his book as a system
uh i think victory you pointed this out
a little while ago right like briary
says
this is what my project is going to be
this is the terminology that i'm going
to use this is what all of it means
here we go right here the three
different ways that we apprehend time
and so on
darity never really works this way uh he
doesn't even go as far as wickenstein
does which is to basically write
aphoristic paragraphs uh on different
points he's always engaging
with some other figure or set of figures
and reading their
text and drawing out deconstructive
ideas and tropes from his interpretation
right
but i can't think of a single therapy
book i've ever read where he's more or
less
here's jacques jarrett his thought uh
and jacques there at his system
uh congratulations you know read this
and you'll understand everything that
i'm going through
even up grammatology which is usually
considered as magnum opus
as eric pointed out uh most of the book
is a reading of sasar
reading uh of rousseau uh and then if
you look at specter's remarks it's a
reading of marx
uh of spirit it's a reading of heidegger
lots of stuff interpreting
uh husserl and i think it's very much in
the spirit of what darrett is doing
right where he's saying i'm not trying
to put forward
a new way that you should do things what
i'm doing is interpreting a text and
trying to show you
uh both what the text says on its
surface and all the stuff that
is concealed or repressed beneath it and
this
is why i am kind of like you guys on
strauss in that way
even though they would hate that
comparison i do not think that anyone
who says
darada is obsessed with language or he's
just moving the
the onso theology onto language
understands
derida because the reason he's obsessed
with language is because he says
if we are to read we must remain within
the text
so if he's writing in a language
and reading in a language in a
philosophical tradition
there's nothing else that he could
really talk about while remaining within
the text so he's literally doing the
thing that he says
is all you can do and that's why it
appears that he's obsessed with language
until of course later then he's writing
on uh hospitality and forgiveness and
things like this where i think he's
kind of tired of his project a little
bit being too linguistic
but i mean that would be my rejoinder to
the accusation that he's too linguistic
yeah and like if the text is the history
of whether western metaphysics and like
the broader sense then
then he says we don't have any language
that's alien to this history
everything we have comes from it and it
makes
and it wouldn't make sense anyway to
critique western metaphysics
without this language all we have
is the this these propositions that are
already
in the form and he says the logic of
precisely what it seeks to contest
so we only have the tools that we have
inherited
before in order to critique then the
tradition that they come from
that's that's what he's sort of getting
at with this language
and this text thing and another
important thing to describe
so if you want to get to what darida has
to do with semiotics right so he's going
to
talk about the way that language
has been divided so you have spoken
language and you have written language
and from the beginning from aristotle on
down to
rousseau they say that spoken language
is primary
writing is derivative of spoken language
right and he he's attacking this
as well because writing for him he wants
to take it
seriously and the reason that semiotics
comes into play is because the sign
right a sign is something that stands
for something else that is not present
that's the whole idea presence is
announced
by speech right because speech requires
the presence of the speaker
and so he critiques this whole notion
that
well he calls it logocentrism the the
center
this using speech spoken
language and writing phonetic writing as
it's sort of handmaiden
and semiotics comes into play because
the sign is
indicating something that's absence a
sign is always something that stands for
something that's not there
and that's even so sir says this he says
the sign is a sound pattern connected to
a concept
and the written form of the sign is just
derivative of this the written form of
the sign indicates the spoken
word and darida wants to explode this
because on the one hand
you have things like religion which are
based on the presence of speakers and
ultimately the second coming the second
presence of god
and then you have science who says okay
great if if writing
is not bound to speech
then i can take writing and turn it into
a purely sort of formal system of signs
in order to describe the universe
so you have this sort of double
tradition of science and
philosophy that he's critiquing based on
this
distinction between spoken language and
just writing
and that's why a lot of it like writing
and difference is the title of one of
the major releases because he wants to
sort of get back to writing and take
play at taking writing seriously
because writing it writing introduces
difference that's this
and difference yeah and that concept of
this is again
performative because it's spelt
it i mean you can't see that it's a
different word until you read it so he's
kind of undermining the superiority or
supposed superiority of speech
by saying here's something that speech
can't notice
which is quite a clever play yeah
there's certain differences
yeah there's certain differences that
only appear in in writing so when
if you're a frenchman you have those two
words a
and a right is an and and
like if you're not listening very
carefully they can sound the same the
difference
actually only appears in writing same
with difference right he changes the
letter
a instead of an e and again difference
difference you won't hear
the difference in speech but in writing
the difference appears
so again there's a the speech has a kind
of
you'd say constitutive lack that writing
is the supplement for writing becomes a
supplement
in order to complete speech and he's
saying this is the sort of
this is the matrix of western thought
is this sort of ordering of being in
this way with speech at the top and
presence
at the tippy top and then absence at the
bottom
and right what's the sign of absence all
the way up until so sir
writing is the sign of absence written
signs because they indicate
a and absent speaker and be an absent
object that's being referred to
and so all we really have when we're
doing semiotics now or semiology after
so sir is the
is a sound pattern that's formal and
memorized i guess you could say
conditioned linguistic preconditioning
and concepts that indicate
absent things that are just in our mind
so when anglophone speakers
say difference and put the emphasis on
that
on that changed letter you're actually
ruining darada's point
by drawing attention to it in speech so
you have to take the particularities of
language into account when you're doing
this stuff too
so i'm gonna i'm gonna have to duck out
here guys but this was fun um
do you want me to just like record a
quick goodbye and you can just pretend
like i
like you can change it or do or does it
matter like how do you want to do it
uh sure just record a goodbye see you
victor
see ya see you i don't know i don't know
i just don't know or if you just like i
mean i doubt i'll
yeah anyway you want us to clap so you
know where i left
no i'll see it this is the primacy of
speech over
rk writing or techno race writing paper
this is
thanks for doing it earlier too this
worked out well so yeah i don't know
all right later your trace will remain
with us
the ghost oh guys our derrida jokes were
so clever
i know i know so we could there's so
many
like i think if we're gonna continue
this we can pick maybe
one term to focus on because there's
like rk writing we could talk about the
timpin
we could talk about the metaphor of
light uh you could talk about the army
of
metaphors the farmicon matt you oh
pharmacon 2
matt what are you saying no well i just
wanted to
riff off of one thing that eric said uh
before we move into discussing is
shall we say esoteric terminology right
um because
this point uh does actually have pretty
serious political implications for a lot
of people
right which is why he's had impact in
political
uh and legal theory and cultural theory
beyond what you might expect from
somebody who focuses on semiology at
least in this early text right
so one example that i gave earlier on is
uh the way different postcolonial
critics have picked up his work right
the other one that i really want to talk
about because i think it's actually more
significant
and it's actually more germane to a lot
of the conflicts uh around derrida's
work politically
as the way feminists have interpreted
his theories right
because one of the things that they've
pointed out feminist iridians right or
at least
sympathetic feminist readers of darida
is that
one of the forms uh uh one of the things
that have been privileged in the history
of western metaphysics
uh has been a concept of masculinity
over femininity right
uh and the interesting thing is this is
linked to a whole host
of different concepts like reason
strength
uh logocentrism uh and so on
uh all of which are described masculine
qualities versus feminine qualities
which tend to be associated with things
like
chaos emotion uh disorder
right uh etc etc etc uh
and one of the things that like feminist
meridians like to do is showcase how
uh not only uh are these different
concepts actually interdependent on one
another
in much the same way as what one
considers uh to be masculinity is highly
dependent on
usually this very negative uh
interpretation of what femininity
happens to be
it's that once you deconstruct these uh
you realize that
our entire conception of what it means
to be a man or a woman
uh is a lot looser and more problematic
than we thought and much more dependent
on this constipated vision
of history of the history of gender and
its associated terms
right and this is why a lot of
postmodern
uh feminists have actually tended to
problematize things like
the sex gender division in a way that
earlier second wave feminists wouldn't
right uh since from darren's
interpretation
the perspective of deridian feminists uh
they were still attached to this much
more binary way
of looking at sexual difference yeah we
can talk about an example
here quickly um christeva
yeah is her name is it pronounced yulia
or juliash i think she's bulgarian
i'm not sure we don't have litvic here
anyway uh the example that she gives
there's a a phrase in plato's taimaeus
where he's also drawing this distinction
between
something called a korra and the kora
is like a an empty space
between the forms basically so it's
emptiness which is exactly the opposite
of presence in this uh discussion it's
also like the periphery as opposed to
the center kind of thing too isn't it
right it's an outside empty so it's
non-designated space
so uh christeva reads this and unmarked
and because it's unmarked plato
considers it unimportant
and then christeva's reading of this in
deridian fashion is like this is exactly
the place that
woman concept woman has uh
compared to the man the ma she's the
empty space
and then goes into this entire
discussion of korra as this
non-designated space but connects it to
like
the recep the mother's womb um
and and draws out a whole rich history
of why this
this abject or not that's the wrong term
why this uh
forgotten or non-designated space is
considered
not important but it actually is the
space in which the forms appear
so it's important yeah and and you could
definitely use
derrida's idea of deconstruction to look
at those oppositions
they kind of line up in a strange way
because what you're talking about the
we were saying like the center in the
periphery the uh the marked and the
unmarked
so those tend to come in binaries right
like nature
culture man woman like western and
non-western they tend to come in
binaries and one term is the mark term
and the other term is the unmarked term
one term is important
and the other term is completely
considered unimportant
but what dairy that wants to show is
that they secretly depend on each other
in a way right because
all language is taking over from saucer
all the languages is a system of
differences
everything is what it is because it's
different from everything else
a dog is a dog because it's different
from every other
four-legged vertebrate right so a man
and woman are
they're constituted by their difference
not by
positively by what they are which is
what like the biological kind of
argument wants to do is say no there's
actually an essential being of man and
there's an essential being of woman
and derrida wants to say no this is
language we're dealing with and this is
a system of differences
and for so sir he wants to make all
these limitations like when we're
talking about language we're really
talking about speech and not writing
and we're talking about phonetic
alphabets and not
pre-greek or idiographic alphabets like
he critiques all of these sorts of
exclusions again
as reintroducing these western
metaphysical concepts
because you reintroduce dependent
binaries
but if you want to get behind the
dependent binaries you got to take this
idea of difference
to its like logical and almost absurd
limits and to show that
this is the system that we're dealing
with so when
you know when we're doing speech act
theory for example right
we get all these problems with well what
about play acting
play acting is non-serious he says okay
okay then well my system is gonna
exclude
all non-serious statements are excluded
from my system
and there it goes aha well that
exclusion right there you putting
one side of the binary into unmarked
space
serious and non-serious when you put one
part of the binary into this unmarked
space and say it's unimportant let's get
rid of it
dario wants to bring that back in and
say actually this is the most
important move you've made and that's
kind of
and he runs and that's the basic sort of
form of a deconstructive analysis i
guess you could say
yeah i think that's really well said and
i'll give an example that i was thinking
about the other day
uh because a student of mine is writing
a paper on this um but
think about like the in-cell community
or the mgtow uh
men go their own way movement online a
lot of times they take this
pseudo-essentialist approach to
masculinity right where they say
being a man is a really important thing
and it's being denigrated today we're
being victimized
and we don't need women right uh that's
what the mgtow movement is all about
right men go their own way
no more feminine women involved in our
lives right but one of the things that
you've
noticed when you look at this discourse
is the way that they describe
masculinity is almost inherently
negative right we are what women are not
right
women are passionate and emotional we
are reasonable
right uh women are weak we are strong
women
are driven by impulse we're driven by
logic
right uh and there it does you know
gesture with air would probably be
something to say it would be to say well
listen right you're absolutely dependent
on what it is that you're trying to
exclude
in some cases almost rabidly so and the
more you try to demarcate yourself from
what you're trying to exclude
the more you draw attention to the fact
that you're only able to define yourself
in opposition to something right now
that doesn't mean that we can ever get
beyond this
but perhaps by recognizing this in a
deconstructed manner
uh we can play around with our
conceptions
of all these different ideas in a more
fluid and more emancipated manner
right uh where we won't be constrained
uh by
a binary that we're trying to overcome
uh but that's
inherently co-determinative uh as eric
might say right yeah
so the binaries proliferate and we need
to get around them
and one of the big like tragedies i
guess you could say of that
first essay in the 1960s when when he
kind of
deconstructed structuralism was that
like levy strauss never really got over
it
he kind of disliked derrida for
sort of exposing the limits of his
project in that way
at something that was supposed to like
inaugurate his his lordship over
structuralism he never really got over
it but
the the kind of sad part is that derrida
quotes him constantly
and uses his own insights and just sort
of amplifies them
in a way that that brings us
this deconstructive movement this this
entry into post-structuralism actually
comes right out of structuralism
so in a way when people are looking at
structuralism and post-structuralism
or in a cultural sense modernism and
post-modernism
there's a big argument to be made that
they're actually continuous traditions
they're not
there's no solid separation between the
two
like what's the difference between like
in cultural terms a book like ulysses
and high modernism versus something
you'd
see today right they're all littered
with pastiche and
all of these postmodern things but yeah
the sad part is that structuralism kind
of
had post-structuralism in it
like a baby being born already and darry
and i just kind of reached in and pulled
it out and said here's your
here's here's what you've actually been
trying to get to
and so when we get to this point when
we're thinking about
like okay so we can't use binaries
as a kind of essential oppositions that
structure systems anymore we get to this
point where either
we are nostalgic about it and we
sort of mourn the loss of this sort of
clarity
it's like in rousseau or we get to
someone like nietzsche who's
affirmative who's the loss of objective
truth now is something we have to
embrace
and something that's going to help us
move forward so you just end up at this
point where people are either
like mourning the loss like a lot of
what the
a lot of what the modern critics of
derrida are doing they're mourning the
loss of objectivity
or you have people that just affirm it
and embrace it in a
nichian sort of exuberance and they say
great now i'm
liberated from all of these oppressive
concepts
and you know derrida brings us to this
point
in various ways and it's really hard to
sort
of conceptualize how to get past them
because again if we want to
conceptualize getting past it
if we want to think about what's next we
still
are again stuck in the terms that we've
inherited from the same tradition that
we're critiquing
well that's so in a way it's like that's
how you do the play the play is for that
yeah you just have the delusion it's
it's very
it's similar to the liz in that they're
both um
i guess anti-hegelian and i know like
way back when we did hegel i said
something like i can't ever read hegel
properly
like like borno was asking us to and the
reason is because of
darida and deliz and now we're covering
them
but they're so against totality and so
getting against
uh like getting stuck and i think
the the success of those kinds of uh
their their modes of thought
is spoken to by the fact like dara does
very much an enigma
in that he there could be no daredevil
today
because no one's no one has a career
like heidegger does today no one's gonna
spend enough time
reading carefully reading humbly combing
over every noun and the etymology of
words
in someone else's text we don't have
those error texts anymore
because everyone's trying to you know
advertise themselves and
and quickly get quickly get books out
and move from one thing to the next so
to be fair
both heidegger and uh daredevil were
infamous for quickly putting books out
right i mean you pointed out that darren
had three books a year and he carried
that pace on
uh up to the day he died right i mean i
think if you look at his bibliography on
wikipedia which i glanced at
it was something like 50 books and god
only knows how many articles and media
appearances
from 1967 on the way to 2004 when he
passed away but i think he only wrote
like two books in the 70s
he released three all at once and then
like i get why
i don't know i don't know he's a very
careful reader though you cannot
say that he's like putting out [ __ ]
because every book that he writes
on these massive tomes um
are ex they're very slow they're
systematic sometimes you wish you would
go faster because he says the same thing
like it takes him 30 pages to to make a
what could be a quick point um so he's a
little bit frustrating to read but
i wonder do you guys agree with me in
that suggestion that in our
basically because of what the text has
become for us
uh he's a little bit passe
yeah i mean i most people i mentioned
earlier on that
i do think that there's still a kind of
the residual linguistic uh idealism in
daredevil which is why i wouldn't
characterize myself in deridian in any
sense
and i agree with the kind of marxist uh
beijing critiques of him in that respect
just two terms we don't need to get into
that but i will say that he has had
a very positive impact on people who
want to engage
uh in what we might call more totalizing
or systematic kinds of philosophy
precisely because he drew attention to
the need to
be respectful of difference uh in a way
that
earlier philosophies of totality weren't
right
uh and you can see this actually in the
impact uh he's had on people who tried
to carry on
with earlier modes of philosophizing
right so are still marxists out there
who will uh talk about the same kind of
things that marx did there are obviously
still hook aliens out there we'll talk
about the same things that hegel would
but you very rarely see them talk about
the term totality
or the absolute in an unproblematic way
which you usually see are things like
house gzek will talk about uh the
absolute right
uh where essentially um it serves an
ideological function
different systems of power and so we
need to get rid of it
and recognize that the genius of
dialectics is pointing out that nothing
ever arises
uh arrives at an absolute right uh the
kind of tensions inherent within reality
and the breaks within reality are
constant features
not bugs that can be overcome and
thought right
and the same is true and you know the
marxist tradition where people will now
talk about how it is that
uh we can't necessarily ascribe some
kind of teleology to
uh history uh because that implies that
there's some kind of
grand narrative reading that we can give
in it uh if we're gonna carry on
engaging in marxism we need to recognize
that
um structures might be able may be
analyzed in terms of contradictions but
we can't necessarily
say that contradictions inherent within
structures are going to lead to anything
necessarily
right i think that's been a positive
impact uh on people who want to carry on
doing
the more traditional ways of
philosophizing
including myself right i should say
right because i i prefer materialism to
deridianism but
i would always say that any kind of
materialism you're going to do has to
have
posteridian characteristics by the way i
would definitely
we can't have this conversation now but
i don't think you can say
there it is not a matu you just added
idealism to linguistic there and said
that that's what he's doing well i said
residual linguistic idealism and i would
say the same thing about heidegger right
that's not an original claim by me right
people have pointed out how
heidegger's highly critical of hegel uh
and hegel's
absolute idealism but if you look at
heidegger's kind of history of the west
he sometimes says that the best way to
interpret the whole history of western
civilization as he understands it
uh is through the story of its
metaphysics and metaphysical epochs
right so
uh to every epoch there is a thinker who
is appropriate to it uh
that's not derrida that's heidegger no
no that's not daredev but i'd say that
there's certainly still a residual
element of this way of reading the
history of
civilization and if you want to just
call it this discourse the disc like
civilization and his discourses right uh
it's not as prominent as it's in
heidegger but there still is an element
to it but
i don't really want to get into that
yeah sorry
no no no i mean if you're reading
heidegger and derrida
the same then no you're reading one of
them wrong
i don't really want to get into that
yeah we can't have this argument really
far afield
i would introduce your critique of
daredevil and all that kind of stuff
this isn't a critique but i would
think like personally i would just side
with
a project that looks more like deliz
because contrary to what people think
about dairy
dairy does extremely careful and that's
why he says
or that's why i i reiterate
it's assumed that he's more linguistic
than he probably actually thinks about
the world
but he's saying i'm going to stay
textual so i'm a writer
i read i write and i read and that's
what i talk about i talk about books i
read books
whereas i think a deluse project is a
little bit more inspiring
because it goes everywhere it goes
wherever you want it goes schizo
what do you think eric that's for sure i
think we can we'll all become vegetable
by the end of this
becoming minor becoming woman yeah yeah
i mean i i still find structuralism to
be like a very compelling tradition
and i don't think it's i don't think
we're past it in a sense of like being
post
anything just as i don't think
post-modernism is fully past
modernism it's just a sort of new
evolution
like hybrid yeah maybe or
or there's a continuity
there that people want to see a
discontinuity between the two traditions
and i think there's a
major continuity because again like i
said post-structuralism
comes from within structuralism
structuralism like laid the foundations
and in a sense like some some writers
have even made the strange claim that
post-modernism actually came before
modernism
or you look at latour's claim we have
never been modern
so in a way people want to take this
like radically discontinuous view but i
i still
so i still think like structuralism is
very compelling
and i don't think we're past it we're
not post anything
i think derrida just points out its
limits
very well and gets us to think a little
bit harder about
the binary terms that we're using like
one of the biggest ones like self and
other
right like that's that's a huge one and
i think if if you just sort of take that
for granted
in a structuralist sense as structuring
subjectivity there's a self and there's
another
then that's when you're falling back
into idealism but i think i think
derrida
in a way helps us avoid that
pitfall of thinking
and writing and speaking and doing
philosophy
all right i think that's a good place to
end thank you
uh who was it again matt h for the
suggestion
well thank you all for your suggestions
actually
wayne aaron marissa a bunch of people so
we'll do this again
i think we do have to do the debate
that we've been talking about doing yeah
we'll get litvik in here to moderate for
us and then
and then we can put matt on a time limit
which is something i've been wanting to
do
forever we'll give
sorry we'll give litvic the power to
mute
the power to silence that's wise
yeah wait so are we done then uh well
why don't we
i'll leave you with the final point
since it just uh backhand complimented
you
okay well i have to say like um
i have an ambivalent relationship to
daredevil which i think he would
probably appreciate in some senses
because
primarily looking at things from a
political standpoint as i do
uh given my own orientation i think that
this can be tremendously beneficial in
loosening up
old ideological or discursive
expectations about how it is that the
world operates
and create more free spaces for people
to interrogate
expectations and conceptions of the
world that can become
very calcified and rigid and serve to
justify various oppressive systems of
power
i do tend to agree with the fairly
standard criticism of dairy dead that
has been made by everyone from habermas
going forward that it's hard to read any
kind of positive
program into this about what can be done
for the future
and so when people accuse him of being
nihilistic i don't think that that's
necessarily true
but i would say that he's certainly
agnostic about what we should do
going forward and particularly given the
time period that we're in right now i
don't think agnosticism is good enough
right but that doesn't necessarily mean
that we should throw him away or that
there's anything
fundamentally problematic with his work
it just means that we need
to commit ourselves to projects going
forward in the expectation that they're
not necessarily grounded in anything
more foundational than better or worse
interpretations of the world
and i think that's a very radiant
outlook and it's what i think is the
most
interesting thing uh about his work for
political purposes
all right fair enough i wholeheartedly
endorse agnosticism
because everything else makes me tired
you know what i think would be my if i
could go to heaven
and ask god for something it would be
that derek or that jordan peterson would
be stuck in a chair
clockwork orange style and just have
just have
buried out red to him for 100 years
yeah well what sort of music what sort
of music would be playing while his eyes
are
wedged open i don't know what would he
hate probably put on some trap music
no it has to be something he loves so he
so he can associate daridell with it
that's the like the violence the pairing
of the two stimuli that's true
so it's got to be darida paired with i
don't know what is he like
like bach or something some russian
composer
tchaikovsky i don't know the screams of
the screams of snowflake liberals i
guess i don't know
just a just a track playing of people
going
and then he has to read darida anyway
jordan we're glad you're back
we've missed you he's back he's back
down the street again so
anyway uh thanks patrons we
love you and uh
yeah thanks for the suggestions we'll
we'll we'll look back to them and maybe
i'll ask for a new one because i like
the voting system because it takes the
pressure off of us and then we get to
talk about
what we know people actually want to
listen to yeah
yeah get the suggestions rolling so uh
thank you guys
uh i'm gonna hit the record button and i
will talk to you guys
oh wait
[Music]
you